creativity is the core of great science
I'm Paul nurse and I'm president of
Rockefeller University
the training and also the way of
actually carrying out the the profession
is quite different between a scientist
and a doctor understandably so that's
not a criticism of either sigh it's just
how it is so then we mix two sorts of
people like this together in the same
activity and we expect them to work
together it's like mixing some of you
only speak English with French and
assuming it's going to work it won't so
what do we do about that what we have to
do about that its first of all recognize
the problem and analyze it and then
secondly we have to deal with it we have
to get the two individuals types of
individuals to understand their
differences to see where they're coming
from to realize why they have differing
views and how they can perhaps work best
together do you think any of us in the
bio medical profession take the
slightest bit of notice of trying to do
that or smacks of sociology and stuff
like that we don't but this is something
where we really need like in the future
have I applied it successfully in in my
own work my own work has tended not to
involve directly medicine so I've not
been exposed with my own research in
that way but I have seen it many many
times in my colleagues and because I've
led research institutions and I've done
my best to at the very least get mutual
respect on both sides of that divide but
I actually think we need a much more
professional approach that problem and I
would say it's key for greater success
in this area
prevention is really important it's it's
often not given the air time it should
earn by the scientists themselves
because it's quite a difficult subject
to study and often requires very long
term trials sometimes over decades with
large numbers of individuals before you
can get good statistical results so it
does sort of doesn't fit in well with a
normal scientific career if you've got a
PhD or four years say knowing that
you're participating in a study that
takes 20 years to carry out it just
doesn't fit so it's quite difficult to
actually do good working some in some
cases in this sort of area and it's also
a very complicated issue and we all know
of individuals who have smoked 40
cigarettes a day who lived till 90 but
of course we happen to know that if you
do smoke 40 cigarettes a day on average
in the population and your life
expectancy can be reduced 15 or 20 years
I forget exactly the number so it's a
hugely negative impact upon your health
even though certain individuals may
actually survive that so understanding
the interaction between the impact of
environment with with genetics I think
it's really crucial in getting good
preventive advice out there and but this
makes it these epidemiological studies
that's population-based studies as
they're called even more difficult
because you're not only then trying to
simply control for whether an individual
is exposed to a particular environmental
impact such as the Sun or tobacco or
water but which is difficult enough in
itself but you're also saying we need to
subdivide the population up according to
their genetic makeup to get good results
and we may not even quite know how to
divide them up and what which particular
variants of genes are important so these
are difficult problems but we are
beginning to get into the territory
where we can perhaps address them and
maybe that will help us put to rest a
lot of the quackery that can go around
advice about prevent
and I would really like to see that
because there is so much nonsense that
is published out there at the media like
it because it's relatively easy to
understand and it's a bit of a care you
know scare story but if we if we ask
questions like is but a good for your
bad for you I mean I can never remember
because what was the last thing I I read
about it and usually the reasons and
that we as the public get confused about
such matters are that the effects that
are reported are actually pretty small
and it all depends on the context of the
trial let alone the genetic makeup of
the individuals involved in it and we
get blown around like a weather vane by
just the latest report which is often
made to be rather sensational so I I see
this being rather slowly developed
because the the studies have to be so
long term and we're not yet in a good
place for looking at the interaction
screen genetics environment well but I
think it's really important because if
we can give good advice to individuals
about what their lifestyles and that's
going to have a big impact